[Music]
hi friends pastor doug batchelor here
you know periodically someone will uh
email me and they'll draw my attention
to
a youtube where people are saying
something
uh negative and critical about seventh
day adventist
and there's a lot of misinformation out
there on the internet you realize
anybody can say anything and some people
watch these programs
and they're easily persuaded but you
know i thought it would be maybe helpful
if i took one of these and i went
through point by point
some of the criticisms that people have
where they're saying that seventh-day
adventists are a cult
or you need to watch out for seventh-day
adventists i appreciate this one that
was produced by the masters seminary
we're gonna play it for you
i'm gonna pause it along the way i like
it because they
basically broke the criticisms down into
three easy to understand
points and so just be with me now let me
just tell you
i am a seventh-day adventist christian i
have not always been i used to go to
church on
sunday and i attended other
denominations when i continued to read
the bible and i learned the bible truth
i became a seventh-day adventist nobody
in my family was a seventh-day adventist
i realized that it might make me
unpopular in some circles
but i wanted to go by the scriptures so
with that little introduction
i'd like to get into this video i'll
just play segments of it
i'll stop it along the way and i'll do
my best to be fair and let them
make their points hi i'm jamie jackson
with the master of seminary and joining
me right now is dr nate bruce it's dr
bruce thanks so much for
joining me absolutely i want to talk
about uh
seventh day adventism how should we
as believers view that denomination
well even the word denomination is one
that raises questions in the minds of
some evangelicals should seventh-day
adventism be
considered a denomination okay i gotta
pause right there because
they're saying now first of all this is
dr nathan booznitz
and he is a teacher at the masters
seminary in los angeles california
we've never met seems like a nice enough
gentleman be happy to
talk to him be happy to debate him on
some of these issues publicly if he was
interested
but he said that seventh-day adventists
should not even be considered a
denomination
well i think that that was maybe a
little over the top because the word
denomination simply means
it's the way of naming or classifying
things uh all
denominations need a name
to identify them to register to show
they're
separate to put a name on the building
to say something the adventist cannot be
a denomination is like saying
that the one dollar bill is telling the
five dollar bill you cannot be a
denomination well they're both
denominations they're named they're
classified
and so yes we can be classified
historically it's been regarded as a
cult though there are some in
more recent decades who want to have
more of an open
attitude towards adventists i'm talking
about an evangelical perspective so
so the question is one that has been
raised all right so
they're basically saying that there's
disagreement among evangelicals about
whether or not seventh-day adventists
should be classified as a cult
a number of years ago donald barnhouse
and walter martin wrote a book
they worked together in a book i think
martin principally wrote the book called
kingdom of the cults
and the conclusion of that book was
seventh-day adventists are not to be
categorized as a cult
historically the adventist movement
actually started in the early 19th
century in the 1800s
there was a man named william miller
william miller believed
through his study of scripture that he
had figured out when jesus was going to
come back
he said jesus was going to return
sometime between march 21
1843 and march 21st 1844.
the lord jesus did not return and so he
adjusted his date and said no it's going
to be october
22nd 1844. his followers were known as
the millerites
and when jesus didn't come back on that
date they experienced what they call the
great disappointment
and obviously miller's calculations
his predictions did not come true i just
want to
what he's saying is correct right now
william miller who is a baptist preacher
he did do some incredible
prophetic bible study he came to the
date of 1844 when he studied the
prophecies in daniel chapter eight
and it said the sanctuary would be
cleansed he thought that meant that the
earth was the sanctuary to be cleansed
by fire
even though there's really nothing in
the bible that says that the earth was
to be considered the sanctuary
seventh the adventists were not
organized as a denomination until 1863.
so i just want everyone to have
a picture of the span that took place
between the great disappointment
in 1844 and the organization of the
seventh-day adventist as a denomination
in
about 1863. most people realized that
his calculations had been wrong but
there was a small group who said wait a
second maybe his calculations
aren't wrong maybe it's just the event
he associated with his calculations that
is wrong
the early seventh-day adventists came up
with the doctrine of what they call
christ's
heavenly work of atonement what they say
is that on october 22nd 1844
jesus went from the the holy place
in the heavenly sanctuary into the holy
of holies
to continue a second work of atonement
in heaven
something they call a work of
investigative judgment
it's not seventh-day adventists that
manufactured the teaching that christ is
still
ministering in the heavenly temple and
yes we do believe
that the work of heavenly ministry of
jesus is still going on
this is a bible teaching and
well i should i should let him continue
with what he's saying here
and give people the whole picture so
that's how the whole movement got
started and a young woman named ellen
harmon
later married ellen g white is her
married name
she began to receive visions through
these visions that she
received supposedly she gave
really the the basis to the
seventh-day adventist movement so let's
talk about
uh the sabbath because obviously they
meet on saturday but
they have a wrong view of what the
sabbath is
biblically speaking well yeah i would
say that there's really
three big problems with seventh-day
adventist doctrine
three major reasons why evangelicals
should be very concerned
and why they shouldn't just embrace
adventism
as a denomination it's it's not a
denomination it's something that really
is
outside of evangelical biblical
christianity
three reasons why number one would be
that they
do have in spite of some of the
statements that they make about
salvation being by grace
they really do have a legalistic
understanding of the gospel
and that's seen in their insistence that
christians observe the sabbath
and that christians observe certain
dietary laws out of leviticus
11 and so on all right
are are we legalists why is he saying
we're legalists
because he says we insist that people
keep the sabbath
is it seventh-day adventists that create
the ten commandments
or is god commanding are these the ten
recommendations
if seventh-day adventists were telling
people they should turn from their sins
stop killing
stop lying stop committing adultery are
you then categorized as a legalist for
doing that
we did not write the ten commandments
this is a bible teaching that we are to
encourage people to turn from sin
we just believe that you need to put the
sabbath truth in the same category as
the other ten commandments
it's right in the middle of the ten
commandments it begins with the word
remember
and so do you become a cult because you
believe in all ten commandments
instead of just nine or eight
commandments um
and then he goes on to say that uh well
we're legalists we believe
in righteousness by faith that we're
saved by grace
if you look for instance in baptismal
vow number three
i accept the death of jesus christ on
calvary as the atonian sacrifice for my
sins
and believe that through faith in his
shed blood i am saved from
sin and its penalty so this is our
official teaching
by the way you'll notice that dr booznet
in his
comments he never opens up any book he
never quotes from any document he sits
in front of a sign of master seminary
and he basically shoots from the hip our
official teachings make it very clear
we do believe in salvation by faith but
we also believe that jesus said
people need to turn from their sins
christ began teaching repent for the
kingdom of heaven is at hand
john the baptist repent for the kingdom
of heaven is at hand
the apostles repent and be baptized
repent of your sins
what a sin transgression of god's law so
if you're still part of a church
that's teaching the 10 commandments
you're a legalist
but i'll get to that a little more in
just a minute so we'll carry on
the apostle paul addresses those issues
in colossians 2
16-17 makes it very clear that as
christians as those who are no longer
bound by the old covenant because we are
under the new covenant in christ
that we're not bound to observe the
sabbath or observe dietary laws
the rest of the new testament really
underscores the fact that believers met
on the first day of the week the day of
christ's resurrection
okay well he mentioned colossians
chapter 2 verse 13 let's read that and
find out what paul is saying here
colossians 2 start with verse 13 and you
being dead
in your trespasses in the uncircumcision
of your flesh
he's made alive together with him having
forgiven all of your trespasses
having wiped out the handwriting of
requirements that was against us now
ten commandments were not written by a
man's hand they were written by the
finger of god
the bible talks about the ceremonial
laws and the ceremonial sabbaths that
were written by the hand of
moses it actually uses that phrase
having wiped out the handwriting of
requirements which was against us
why does it say against us well because
the bible says
that the ceremonial laws were placed in
a pocket outside of the ark of the
covenant
that it might be a witness against you
never said that about the ten
commandments
having wiped out the handwriting
requirements that was against this
which was contrary to us taking it out
of the way having nailed it to the cross
this year's clearly talking about the
handwriting of moses
which was put on parchment it's nailed
to the cross
those ceremonial sabbaths and laws they
were put in a pocket on the outside of
the ark
and god said that it may be a witness
against you the very language used here
is talking specifically
about the ceremonial laws and sabbas ten
commandments have not been wiped away
the only one of the ten commandments
they have a problem with is the fourth
commandment
that begins with the word remember the
sabbath day you're not a legalist if you
teach
all 10 you're being biblical
having disarmed principalities and
powers he made a public spectacle of
them
triumphing over them in it so let no one
judge you in food or in drink or regard
of a festival or a new moon or
sabbaths and sentence doesn't end
sabbaths which
are a shadow of things to come but the
substances of christ
those sabbaths that are nailed to the
cross are the annual
feast days of the jews christians
historically from the time
of christ to the present day have
all believed that the sabbath should be
kept it's only in recent years they're
saying the ten commandments
were nailed to the cross and we've just
reattached nine of them
which is really an absurd teaching and i
would ask
these gentlemen do they go to church on
sunday where is the command in the new
testament to go to church on sunday
they say well the bible says that this
is the teaching where
where does it say show me one command in
the whole bible that we are to now
keep the first day of the week as the
new sabbath there is no command
and so they say well it was the habit of
the disciples to meet on the first day
of the week
there are occasions they met on the
first day of the week and it says and
they met daily
and they met thursday for the lord's
supper and jesus died on friday
and he rested in the tomb on the sabbath
and he rose sunday
never declared it to be a new sabbath
day
so this is all based upon a myth
that has no scripture to support it okay
we're going to go back and play a little
more
one big concern is this legalistic
understanding of what's required for
christians the sabbath
dietary laws etc okay dietary laws
the dietary laws are not a jewish law
the bible tells us that god gave adam
and noah
dietary laws by the way the whole world
is in a lot of trouble right now because
eve ate something
and adam they were not supposed to eat
and
what parent is going to ever tell their
children we don't really care what you
eat you just pray over it
of course we care what our children eat
because we love them
god cares what his children eat and god
told noah
when you take the animals on the ark
take the clean ones by seven
the unclean ones two by two they were
not to be used for food or for sacrifice
this is a bible teaching even in the new
testament peter says
not so lord i have never eaten anything
common or unclean
and so it was the teaching of the
disciples and of jesus
all through the bible not to eat unclean
foods
is this work of heavenly atonement we
know from the book of hebrews that
christ's work of atonement was
once for all on the cross hebrews
chapter 10
after he completed that once for all
sacrifice he sat down at the right hand
of the father
okay he says that we believe that
the work of christ in heaven is not
complete
well that's true that's what the bible
teaches he's making it sound like
because we believe that jesus has a
continuing work in the heavenly
sanctuary that we don't believe his work
on the cross was adequate or sufficient
seventh the adventist 100 believe that
the sacrifice of christ and the blood he
shed was
adequate and sufficient to provide
salvation for the sins of the whole
world
that he doesn't need to be sacrificed
again that is a one-time work it is
complete
even ellen white who they later will
accuse of being the foundation for our
teachings
supports that the work of christ is
complete she wrote in manuscript 128
1897 our great high priest
completed the sacrificial offering of
himself when he suffered without the
gate
then a perfect atonement was made for
the sins of the people
and here's one more the sacrifice of
christ is sufficient
he made a whole efficacious offering to
god the human effort without the merit
of christ
is worthless that's the review in herald
august 19 1890
but the idea that christ's atonement is
over it's not an adventist teaching that
is a bible teaching
if you look in the bible when jesus died
on the cross
that wasn't the end of his ministry as
our high priest he continues his work as
a high priest
look for instance in hebrews 9 verse 11
but christ came as high priest of the
good things to come that's future
with greater and more perfect tabernacle
not made with hands
that is not of this creation bible says
there's a heavenly temple
all you've got to do is read in isaiah i
saw the lord on his throne surrounded by
the two shekinah cherubim
you read in revelation 1 jesus is
appearing among the seven candlesticks
revelation talks about the altar of
incense revelation talks about the altar
of sacrifice
revelation talks about the ark of the
covenant all the furniture that you
found in the earthly temple we see in
heaven
in revelation and in the prophecies of
zachariah ezekiel isaiah
and so this is a bible teaching and then
look in hebrews here
hebrews 6 20. it says where the
forerunner has entered for us even jesus
having become a high priest forever
according to the order of melchizedek
christ is our high priest he has entered
into heaven
he is interceding in our behalf there
that's this next verse
hebrews 7 24 but he because he continues
it's not over
he continues forever he has an
unchangeable priesthood
therefore he is also able to save to the
uttermost
those who come to god through him since
he
always lives to make intercession for
them
jesus is our high priest he is still
saving people he is still
stretching out his nail-pierced hands
before the father as our mediator
so the idea that the work of atonement
is over
that's not true the the sacrifice is
over yes but the
the atonian work of jesus is not over uh
christ is still interceding for his
people up there
now when you look at the earthly
sanctuary the altar was the first thing
that you saw when you entered into the
sanctuary that's like the cross that's
where the sacrifice took place
it was not the end it was the beginning
and then you went on to
the labor there's you get the baptism
and the fire the altar the holy spirit
and you went into the
holy place and ultimately to the most
holy place the cross is the beginning
if the cross was the end how come we're
still here it's just so obvious that the
plan of salvation is still playing out
christ for whatever reason he's
said that his work is not done in
transforming
the church he wants a church that's
going to represent him when the children
of israel were brought out of egypt
was the sacrifice of the lamb the last
thing they did before they entered the
promised land or the first thing they
did before
they left egypt it was the first thing
it was the beginning of a journey
so this gentleman saying that the
sacrifice is the end
well it is sufficient it is adequate but
the work of christ goes on we don't
believe there's a second sacrifice
or a second atonement that takes place
nothing in the new testament indicates
that he's performing a
second work of atonement in i don't
believe that
so this idea of adding to christ's work
of atonement
is really problematic and even the
investigative judgment
side of it christ is looking at people's
works to see who's worthy to enter
heaven
that again is a works based legalistic
believing that christ
is looking at works is works based and
this is some adventist teaching friends
let me read it to you this is not from
an adventist book this is from the bible
revelation 20 verse 12
and i saw the dead small and great
standing before god
and the books were open and another book
was opened which was the book of life
and the dead were judged
according to their works by the things
that were written in the books
revelation 22 12 last chapter in the
bible
behold i'm coming quickly this is red
letter words of jesus
my reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his work
you can read the last chapter in
ecclesiastes there solomon says
in chapter 12 14 for god will bring
every work into judgment
including every secret thing paul says
we shall all stand before the judgment
seat of christ
why would you say that a church is
legalistic for teaching
all of the bible not just some of the
bible yes there is a judgment day
we're saved by our faith but we are
judged by our works
and the works show whether or not you've
allowed
the gospel to transform you and to
sanctify you and that you've been
saved it's not legalism see that's kind
of the dirty word that
some churches paint other churches if
you teach the commandments of god
then they try to pin the word legalism
on you make you look like a pharisee
but you know these are the things that
paul said that peter said that james
said that jesus said
paul said it is not the hearers of the
law that will be justified before god
but the doers of the law will be
justified
romans chapter 2 verse 13. and so
believing scripture does not make you
legalistic
legalistic understanding of salvation i
think it's a big problem
and then the third major area of concern
would be with regard to the way lng
white is treated they elevate lng white
as an authoritative
prophetess and anytime
you have a movement that elevates anyone
or anything to a level of equal
authority
and in reality greater authority than
scripture because they say that
scripture has to be interpreted through
the lens of ellen g
white i think you are setting yourself
up for
major major problems all right now that
this is the third she's itemized the
three things the three reasons they say
that
evangelicals are supposed to look at
seventh-day adventists as a cult
one is because we believe all ten
commandments
that i think is absurd the second one is
they say that we
don't believe the work of christ was
completed by the cross
we do believe that the salvation of
christ
provided on the cross is was adequate
for
one time cover the sins of the world is
completely sufficient but the work of
atonement is clearly not
over based on the scriptures that i gave
you that christ is still ministering as
our high
priest in heaven it's true and the third
thing they say that
and i hear this all the time that we put
alan white on an
equal or a higher plane for with the
bible or we must interpret the bible
through ellen white
that is categorically not true now you
know let me just say something
whenever you're trying to find out what
the truth is and you're evaluating what
a church believes
um i've seen this before where you know
there'll be some disaster in a
neighborhood
a hurricane will go through and the news
crew will come in and they jump out of
their truck and they take the microphone
and they walk over to someone who's
standing on the street and all the
neighbors are looking they're going
oh please don't interview him do not
give the microphone to that guy
that is the village idiot every church
especially a church
that's got millions of believers if you
want to take
a letter or writing or an email post and
interview one person say this is what
they believe
that's not fair if you want to find out
what a church believes
go to what the bible says and go to
what their official teachings are and so
if you look at the official teachings of
the seventh-day adventist church
we do not believe that the writings of
ellen white are on an equal plane
higher or that the bible should be
interpreted through the writings of
illinois
let me just give you some stuff on that
if you
join the seventh-day adventist church
you go through a series of 13 baptismal
vows baptismal vow number five reads
this way by the way ellen white's name
does not appear anywhere in our
baptismal vows
it says i believe the bible is god's
inspired word and
it constitutes the only the bible
constitutes the only
rule of faith and practice for the
christian this is not something new this
is what we believe
if you look at the writings of ellen
white
it says the people of god are directed
to the scriptures as their safeguard
against the influence of false teachers
and elusive powers of spirits of
darkness by their testimony
every statement not by my testimony by
their testimony every statement must be
tested
that's great controversy page 593.
here's another statement by ellen white
unless you think that she was saying
her writings are our instruction was to
be
on an equal level or above the bible he
christ
pointed to the scriptures as of
unquestionable authority
and we should do the same the bible is
to be presented as the word of the
infinite god as the end of all
controversy and the foundation of all
faith it would be absolutely abhorrent
to ellen white
to hear anybody in our church say that
her writings were to be put on an equal
level
or above the teachings of christ
and now if you go to the official the
longer not just the baptismal vows but
if you go to our book of 27 fundamentals
it's
a more exhaustive book it says the
official statement in the seventh day
adventist church says
the bible is the standard by which all
teachings and experience must be
tested now you may find
some sympathy adventists out there that
are not balanced and they make too much
of ellen white's writings you know you
can find
lutherans by the way martin luther had a
couple of dreams and visions didn't know
that
and i believe god used luther i believe
luther was inspired
not on the level of the bible but you're
going to find some lutherans they're
always quoting luther
and you're going to find some baptists
in there always quoting calvin as though
calvin is the last word and you're going
to find
some methodists they're always quoting
john wesley and i believe god spoke
through luther and wesley and calvin
i believe that god inspired ellen white
in an even more specific way but she
never called herself a prophetess
but we do believe in the gift of
prophecy
and the bible teaches that this is a
bible teaching
first corinthians 12 verse 9 and 10
to another talking about the gifts of
the spirit by the same spirit
the gifts of healing by the same spirit
to another working
of miracles to another prophecy to
another discerning of spirits to another
different kinds of tongues
to another the interpretation of tongues
so one of the gifts of the spirit
is the gift of prophecy you can read in
first corinthians 14 verse 1.
paul said pursue love and desire
spiritual gifts
but especially that you may prophesy
verse 3
he who prophesies speaks with
edification exhortation and comfort to
men
now keep in mind in the early church
they did not view every
prophecy that god may have given a
person as something to be added
added to the canon of scripture you can
read in acts 21 verse 9
speaking of philip it says now this man
had four virgin daughters who did
prophesy
we don't have the books of the four
daughters of philip
and so it was common to believe that the
gift of prophecy is one of the gifts of
the church
before i was a seventh-day adventist i
worshiped a lot with charismatic
pentecostal assembly of god christians
i was in their services they were
jumping up all the time and uttering
prophecies and yet they don't call them
a cult
and so they very much all you got to do
is just turn your channel
on sunday morning you're going to hear
some of these pastors say i've got a
word from the lord and they
they say it's the gift of prophecy so to
categorize a church
as a cult because they still believe in
the gift of prophecy
and we do not believe that the writings
of ellen white are equal to
the bible or on or above the bible
or that the bible should be interpreted
through her teachings
i do evangelism all the time everything
i believe all the doctrines i believe is
the seventh adventist i go right to the
bible
but something you're going to notice is
you bounce around a little bit online
is that when people want to criticize
the seventh adventist church
instead of going point by point through
the doctrinal teachings
what they do is they kind of create a
straw
man argument and they talk about ellen
white
and then they make a big deal out of
that you know just while we're on the
subject trends
here you've got a woman who lived about
87 years for 70 years of her life she
was involved in public ministry her
family supported her in what she was
doing she wrote more than any other
woman in american history
her books are in the libraries a lot of
evangelical pastors have her books and
they use it as an inspired commentary
before they preach i hear them on the
radio and television they will not tell
you
i got this from ellen white but i know
her writings and i can tell when they've
been reading her books i've heard him
quote her
on the radio and she's powerful
powerful you know before you reject
something i recommend
you look at it here we've got a
doctor of theology who's making these
blanket statements no references
no quote he simply sits down in front of
a university sign
that's supposed to give you credibility
so if you're going to buy a box of
cereal read the ingredients if you want
to know what a church believes
look at their official statement of what
they believe see if it matches up with
the bible
so why are they taking all this time and
energy to
undermine or to criticize or to try to
put that
badge of cult on seventh-day adventists
well if you look at the statistics right
now in north america virtually every
mainline
church is in free fall when it comes to
membership
methodists lutherans presbyterians
baptists and a number of the other
mainline churches
their membership is plummeting
seventh-day adventists are still growing
and right now we have about 20 million
members it is a movement
people are turning back to the bible and
that and they're finding out what the
bible really says
there's been a great revival a primitive
bible study
and people are saying yeah why don't we
keep the sabbath why aren't we following
you know all these guidelines and
teachings in the bible and so
it's been moving and they're frankly a
little threatened by that
once again if you're blessed by these
programs we'd encourage you to go ahead
click the like button i'd invite you to
subscribe
to my channel and then pass on the good
news to your friends
god bless and don't forget if you'd like
more information
on what the bible really says about the
law and grace
is obedience legalism we'll give you
this free book it's called
does god's grace blot out the law just
click on the link below
and it will be yours read it and share
it with others
god bless
[Music]